hey guys Pete here I need your help the
nominations for the Golden Globes were
announced and we've learned that two of
the most formidable characters from Game
of Thrones in Westworld
are pitted against each other for Best
Supporting Actress okay I'm not having
an existential crisis or anything I mean
it's good news that they're both
nominated I just can't figure out who
should win if you haven't seen the news
and don't know what I'm talking about
the two characters involved are Queen
Cersei Lannister first of her name
played by Lena Headey who do you mind to
step aside or there will be violence
but you find it and mave Malay who is
played by Thandie Newton so you're done
with your little side income probably
your job to seeing as you have ambitions
in my line of work let me tell you what
I tell my new girls never start
something you're not going to finish and
if you're getting [ __ ] either way go
with the lucrative version sweetheart
when I think of too big ensemble cast
like these there's really no shortage of
acting talent
however when someone stands out in this
kind of supporting role it really is
impressive considering how much great
acting is involved with each episode
there's a couple things to factor into
this predicament I'm having the first is
that Lena Headey has been a favorite for
a long time and has yet to actually win
one of these awards she gets nominated
time and time again but it always seems
to get edged out
[Music]
what are they doing here protecting me
yes you will you let me in no I don't
think so if I wanted to kill you do you
think I'd let her wooden door stop me on
the other hand Sandy Newton doesn't seem
to be going anywhere in the show and her
character's role looks like it's
actually even gonna maybe increase a
little bit in season two so that's one
thing another thing is that old Circe
probably isn't gonna live through this
season and if she does can't really see
her character living all the way to the
end for the final six episodes of season
8 so this may be a window although I'm
sure she'll have a great chance after
the season coming up at the same time
Maeve could get into it with Dolores and
that could spell trouble if they don't
see eye to eye but we've got a long way
to wait to find out about that now as
far as characters are concerned I pretty
much have a love to hate relationship
with Cersei I mean she has very
memorable scenes but as a leader and as
someone who you would want to have on
your side
she doesn't really hold up as being
someone who who makes a lot of smart
decisions maybe is also a bit of a
liability since she only really seemed
concern with herself until the very end
of last season I mean we saw glimmers
where she you know had feelings for
Clementine
and the situation that they were all in
but she was really just trying to get
herself out of the park
you're not going to tell anyone anything
[ __ ] you can't hurt me with this you
can't hurt anyone
condi it turns out your friend here is a
much more talented young man than anyone
gave him credit for what the [ __ ] did
you do
calm down so listener I know what about
you I don't need one of those things to
know what you're thinking because I was
built to read people just by looking at
me to know what they want before they do
one thing that they both have in common
that kind of gives them their human
element even though Maeve is obviously
not human is that the one thing that
kept Cersei from being completely evil
was her love for her children as
misguided as it may have been in the
portable decision she made as a result
that's something we can look at and say
well she is a mother who cares for her
children Maeve also has this kind of
connection although her child is a host
she knows that her child's a host and
she actually is a host to and knows that
she's a host so I'm not really sure how
that works except for that you know they
both have things that they care about
except for that search these children
are now dead and I think it's safe to
say that we're gonna see a pretty
serious nosedive in the complete evil
for the future of Queen Cersei but
regardless of their flawed characters
that we'd love to hate or hate the love
or whatever both actresses are
completely on top of their game as far
as I'm concerned neither one is set up
to be the fan favorite but they both put
on a clinic whenever they get a chance
to have a big scene
I remember seeing their bodies hanging
high above the gates of Casterly Rock My
Father let them rot up there all summer
it was a long summer
now the rains weep oh they're holes and
not a soul to hear
if you have a call me sister again I'll
have you strangled in your sleep
after all we've been down this road
before done I thought you looked
familiar when you walked and took me a
minute
that's what you know one of them
analysis
why did tricking you around speak
man-to-man or rather whatever it is we
are
we are
don't matter
it's got a keen sense of irony on Jayla
would I see the magic takes a thief to
catch one so help me decide or tell me
what you guys think do you think that
one of these actually is better than the
other and why do you dislike both of
them because you don't like the
characters that they play or don't like
the stories or something along that
lines if you were stranded on a desert
island and all you could do was watch an
infinite loop of one or the others
character scenes would you choose Cersei
or would you choose Maeve and which do
you think has the better actual story
behind the character just let me know
what you think and don't forget to like
the video for me it's kind of tough to
decide because Cersei sorta came on
slowly it was a few seasons before I
realized what a fun character she was to
watch and then on the other hand Maeve
was just cool right out of the gate once
she started to wake up and became a
super host Thandie Newton actually gets
some bonus points for liking a couple of
my tweets in the past that warms my
small little nerdy heart but otherwise
they're pretty they're pretty evenly
matched I think so the book giveaway is
still going on make sure you leave a
comment here after you subscribe when I
hit 28,000 subscribers I will give away
a copy of the new 20th anniversary
edition of a game of Thrones to one
lucky commenter all you have to do is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
or any of my other videos where I
mention this giveaway for a chance to
win thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon